bonjour à tous une question simple un
basique à coire connaissez vous un
leader
qu'est ce qui vous permet de prédire que
quelqu'un va être capable d'influencer
de convaincre d'entraîner les autres
pour faire quelque chose de grand à les
y réfléchissez mais je vous paraît que
moi je peux deviner le mot qui est venu
à l'esprit de la plupart d'entre vous
derrière ce mot il ya un peu de la
vision de steve jobs il ya d'exemplarité
de gandhi le courage de de gaulle il ya
l'éloquence de luther king a peut-être
aussi un peu d'anti conformisme comme
chez richard branson
et puis il ya la séduction et puis une
aura aussi ce mot se noie il vient du
grec et signifie grâce divine le
charisme
aujourd'hui pour être reconnu comme un
bon dirigeant il faut être reconnu comme
un leader et pour être reconnu comme un
leader il faut avoir du charisme
c'est ce qu'on attend de nos dirigeants
c'est ce qu'on attend de nos leaders et
c'est comme ça qu'on les fabriques et
c'est comme ça qu'on les fabrique depuis
50 ans parce que voyez-vous cette
définition que nous avons du leader ce
stéréotype
il n'a pas vraiment changé depuis 50 ans
c'est ce que montrent les recherches
récentes en leadership ce stéréotype il
reste le même mais plutôt que d'aligner
des chiffres et des statistiques laissez
moi vous raconter une expérience a été
menée l'année passée par deux chercheurs
finlandais
on est dans une business school une
salle de classe en cours de stratégie
un prof une cinquantaine d'élèves âge
moyen 22 ans
voilà les d'exercice que donne le
professeur il demande à ses étudiants
d'imaginer la fin d'une histoire et de
l'écrire et cette histoire c'est peu ou
prou imaginé ça fait 1 ça vous êtes dans
une entreprise appelons-la alpha cette
entreprise depuis un an elle a un
nouveau directeur général
et puis on vous demande dans le cadre
d'une enquête admettons climat social de
donner votre avis sur dirigeants et sur
cette première année de mandat à ce
moment là les étudiants va les répartir
en deux groupes le premier groupe ils
vont recevoir exactement la même
consigne à une toute petite différence
près la petite
on sait que le premier groupe va devoir
raconter son année passée sous la
direction de diane wilson et le second
sont allés passer sous la direction de
david wilson
alors qu'est-ce qui nous racontent les
étudiants une histoire assez sympathique
et classique me dise voilà les deux
bombes ont bien fait le job du dirigeant
ils ont élaboré une stratégie pertinente
ils ont su prendre les décisions qu'il
fallait au bon moment ils ont mené à
bien leur projet motiver leur équipe et
la performance de l'entreprise en a
bénéficié
alléluia good job voilà pour l'histoire
qu'ils racontent tous mais quand on y
regarde de plus près en fait on voit
apparaître quelques petites quelques
petits détails quelques petites
différences et notamment dans la façon
dont les étudiants aura toutes les
raisons du succès alors quand il s'agit
de diana les raisons en sont simples
diana elle est bosseuse elle avait des
compétences des réalisations à faire
valoir
david lui il est une stratégie il a
plutôt bâti raconte-il sur ses qualités
de leader sur son charisme naturel
bref s'il fallait résumer notre diana
elle a été une super dirigeante mais
notre david dein x 7 et peint souffert
dirigeants c'était plus que sarah super
leader voyez le genre qui porte le slip
par dessus pantalon et sa des persos et
de manière très cool
alors si vous me demandez que nous
enseigne que nous enseigne aussi que nos
enseignes cette expérience que pour être
un bon dirigeant il faut être reconnu
comme un leader ok ça on savait que pour
avoir du leadership il faut être connu
charismatique comme charismatique
on savait aussi que quand on est une
femme c'est quand même un peu plus
compliqué d'être reconnu comme un bon
dirigeant est un leader charismatique ça
on le savait aussi
moi je crois que la vraie leçon de cette
expérience est la suivante c'est l'âge
l'âge de nos répondants 22 ans
en fait rien n'a changé dans notre façon
de définir les leaders et nous attentes
à leur égards
rien n'a changé ici vous me demandez
ce que par exemple la génération y est
en train de nous fabriquer comme leader
et bien j'ai envie de vous dire les
mêmes que ceux de nos grands parents
alors je vous entends d'ici mais non
mais pas du tout quel serait le raconte
qu'il ya des études sérieuses qui
montrent que les jeunes ont pas rapport
différent à l'autorité veulent des
managers plus cool qui les écoutent
etc etc oui c'est tout à fait vrai sauf
que ça n'a absolument rien de propre à
la génération y
que vous soyez bébé boumeurs que vous
soyez y que vous soyez x tous ce qui
fait de nous des followers engagé
efficace est heureux c'est qu'on nous
considère et ça c'est ce qu'ont montré
les chercheurs c'est que le levier le
plus puissant de leadership c'est pas
l'héroïsme c'est la considération qu'on
ne porte
c'est ça qui nous donne envie de suivre
quelqu'un pour réaliser quelque chose de
grand
la considération alors c'est quoi le
problème
pourquoi je suis ici en train de râler
un peu le problème c'est qu'on est tous
un peu schizophrène le problème c'est
que dans plein de situations
particulièrement déterminantes comme par
exemple l'oracle d'un concours d'entrée
dans une université comme par exemple un
entretien d'embauché comme par exemple
un entretien d'évaluation annuel dans
toutes ces situations où nous sommes
amenés à être évalué sur notre
leadership ou les autres
on a évalué notre leadership qu'est-ce
qui se passe et bien notre rêve de
leader prend le pas sur notre réalité de
followers nous ouvrions tous et nous
nous mettons à rêver de notre leader
charismatique
alors pour vous démontrer ça je pourrais
vous proposer une petite expérience
pourrait par exemple proposer de
regarder votre voisin de droite
regardez le bien éthique mois s'il
ressemble à un leader regardez le bien
dans les yeux
il ya des signes qui ne trompent pas pas
vrai mais bien vu ok alors vous êtes
peut-être déjà fait un avis pour
certains ma question c'est comment vous
avez fait pour vous faire un avis est-ce
que vous avez regardé autour s'il y
avait des gens qui suivaient des
follower productif heureux et efficace
que c'est ça que vous avez fait en
réalité moi je vais vous dire ce que
vous avez fait vous avez sorti votre
vieille photo jaunie avec l'homme à la
pomme regardez votre voisin ne fait je
ne vois pas un air de famille là non
exceet de la catégorie leaders
moi j'appelle ça le syndrome de la femme
à barbe diana wilson ce que les
étudiants en vacances est amusant dans
les histoires qu'ils disent
david c'est bon pour lui il est parfait
tu rien à faire il continue avec sa cape
et ils s'élèvent dans les cieux c'est
bon diane en revanche elle reçoit plein
de pensées vous ayez devra améliorer sa
communication
elle devrait être un peu plus sensibles
aux besoins des autres parce que bon
quand même son poste de dirigeant ça un
peu érodé sa féminité
donc il ya toujours un petit truc qui
coince avec diana mais vous voyez bien
ce qui coince c'est une sacrée femme à
barbe
pourquoi c'est une femme à barbe parce
que une femme est un leader c'est
bizarre c'est incongru
on sait bien que ça existe mais comme
donc ça nous met un peu mal à l'aise
évidemment ce qui coince avec diana
c'est son genre un leadership ça ne se
conjugue pas au féminin etc si diana de
la catégorie leaders mais excitent aussi
sa fille qui est beaucoup trop jeune
pour être leader et puis sa collègue
aussi les un peu trop introverti moi
j'ajouterais son manager beaucoup trop
sensible surtout pour un homme
bref tout cela par manque de charisme
exit de la catégorie leaders et pas de
ticket pas de ticket divin pour le
leadership c'est fini pour eux je vais
vous dire un secret
on est tous des femmes à barbe on a tous
un truc qui cloche
on est trop grand on est trop femmes on
est trop sensible
on est trop jeune on a tous un truc qui
cloche
vous trouvez ça drôle comme lui
d'ailleurs en fait c'est pas du tout
drôle si l'on considère que pendant ce
temps-là 99% des talents divers chip
disparaissent des radars si pendant ce
temps là on se rend compte du nombre de
talents et de leaders qui vont
disparaître de notre champ de vision et
par voie de conséquence des comités de
direction des entreprises
alors si vous me demandez qu'est ce
qu'il faut faire pour qu'on ait un
leadership disruptif qu'est ce qu'il
faut faire pour qu'on ait un leadership
différents en fait j'ai envie de vous
dire c'est très simple on peut compter
ça nous effraie un peu mais on peut
surtout se réveiller se réveiller de ce
mauvais rêve
ce rêve du héros charismatique se
réveiller commencé par décrocher les
posters mauvaise icône d'accord et puis
repeindre en blanc les murs notre
imaginaire fait une chose pour moi
la prochaine fois vous penserez à ce mot
la prochaine fois que vous penserez homo
leader souvenez vous votre rêve de
leader il est bien moins prometteur que
votre réalité de followers ouvrez les
yeux
regardez autour de vous chercher les
followers
heureux les followers efficace les
followers engagé et lun vous trouverez
des vrais leaders
il suffit d'ouvrir les yeux nous qui
sommes 99% nous les femmes à barbe
nous pouvons juste en nous réveillant en
ouvrant les yeux créer un nouveau modèle
de leadership un modèle de leadership
plus inclusif ouvert à tous et pour ça
les amis on n'a pas besoin de steve jobs